えぇー、復活してから結構日にちが
経ちまして、ようやく僕も大分、You Tuber
っぽく戻ってきたわけなんですけどもー、えーちょっときのしたゆうｙか
大事な話ーかな？
大事な話かはわかんないんですけれども
まあ...
僕が復活する際に
一つ言ったことがあると思います。
あ、かっこいいでしょ。
復活する前に
ひとつ言ったことがあると思うんですけど
こーーー
なんて言ったかも忘れちゃったなぁー
とりあえずもうね、あの一人でやっていく自信が無い的なことを言ったと思います。
復帰してからもう一か月くらいたってるな
まあ、その言ったことの意味としては
まあ一人で休止するまでがーっとやってきたんですけども
静岡東京間を行きしている間に
いろんなことをこなしてるうちに
俺これ多分一人じゃ無理だなと思って
そもそも僕、東京に行っている間動画撮れないんです、落ち着いて
なんか静岡で一人で落ち着いて撮りたい人間だったんですけど
もうそれ無理だなと思って
結構諦めてた時とかあって
それでもやっぱ東京に行かないといけないから
うーん
まあ、言うたらもうほぼ無理やり撮ってね
ちょっと自分の中で妥協したりして動画を撮って編集してアップしたりってゆう
ほんとなんてゆうか
凄い楽しかったんですけど
もっとな...
もっとこう...時間が欲しいなと思っていることが休止前からずっとありまして
そういう意味も込めて一人でやっていく自信が無いと
復活する際に言いました
で、今僕は一人でやっているわけじゃ無くて
前にも言ったんですけど、友達が一人お手伝いっていうかサポートで来てくれてて
動画の時はまさきが、たまに出てくれたり後輩が手伝ってくれたりして動画をやってるんですけども
今後ちょっとどうしていこうかというなかで
僕お休み中に一つ...決めごとをしておりまして
今回その
約束事
休止中に決めた一つを
ちょっと皆さんに...
発表しようと思っていたところなんですけども
動画のタイトルを見れば分かりますね？
はいっ..
ずっと一人で動画やってるように見えますけども
動画を始めた時はグループでやってました実は。
今さらながら恥ずかしいんですけども
はじめカンパニーというふざけた名前で
何人かの友達で最初youtubeやってたんですけども
やる気のなくなったメンバーがいたり
彼女とのもめ合いで辞めたメンバーがいたり
こういろんな事があって結局僕が一人
プラスこう、まさきが手伝ってくれるっていう感じで今まで来たんですけども
元をたどれば僕って皆で撮る動画が実はスタートだったんです。
で今回新しく入るメンバーというのが
という方です
みんな知ってる？
もうこれ知ってるか知ってないかが不安なんですけども
二年前くらいまでいたんですけど
で、今もう就職しちゃって
もう彼は自分の道を行ってたんですけども
もういろいろ僕が話しまして
編集はもう友達がいるんですけども
撮影がちょっと一人だと辛い時があるなとか
忙しすぎて限界をちょっと感じたりしている
ってことを相談した結果
んも、そんな簡単に決めたわけじゃないっすよ
もういろいろ話しましたからね
すごい、いろいろ話した結果
彼が、戻ってきます
俺がもう戻しました
一緒に頑張っていこう、ということで
新メンバーとして戻ってくることになりました
ちょっと本人いなくて申し訳ない
（電話呼び出し中...）
!!
た）あれ？　もしもーし
もしもーーし！！
た）うわあー！
wwwwwwww
た）うわあびっくりした
もしもしーこんばんわ
wwwwww
こんばんわ
仕事忙しい？
た）あー仕事ですか
はいはい
た））実に順調でございます
あ、順調！
というわけで、たくみさんよ
た）はい
いよいよ今日言ってしまったよ
た）いやあ、
た）思えば
た）いつかこうなるような気がしていたよ
いやあ俺もね本当はね、本当はだよ
た）うん
ほんとはこう一緒にyoutubeやっていきたかったけど
なかなかこう誰かの人生を背負う自信もなくて
なかなか誘えなかったんだけど
た）やあ...
た）俺もね、大学卒業して会社に
た）内定だってなって最初は、その...
た）内定内諾書を出しに行く時から
た）一緒に将来どうなるんだろうねって話しながらきてて
た）なんとなくその時からこんな日がいつか来るんじゃないかなって
た）ずっと思っては、いて
うん
た）それでもやっぱり
た）今の仕事もすごいすごい良い人達にかこまれてたし
た）仕事の内容も結構好きだったし
た）それでもやっぱり
た）今回誘われたとき
た）なんて言うんだろう...
た）もう聞いた瞬間から心は決まっていたところがあって
た）これから一緒に頑張っていきましょう
よろしくお願いします
た）よろしくお願いします
た）こちらこそです
た）いやあー
もうでもね一緒にくるとやっぱこう不安定な仕事だからさ
何が起こるか分かんないからさ
た）確かに分からない
何かあった時は..一緒になんとかしようぜ！
た）なんとかしていこう！
た）絶対大丈夫だよ
うん、大丈夫きっと
俺たちなら何とかできるよ
来月、来月くらいだっけ
た）正式に
た）youtubeの人なるっていう日は
おなｎ
じゃあちょっと待ってるよ
じゃあ最後に皆様に一言
た）皆様に一言
はい
た）えっとです
た）youtub(ぶちっ)
はい、というわけでですね
たくみふくしゃちょーが帰ってきます
正直もう...
彼の人生を背負うといっても過言ではないから
プレッシャーが凄いのはまあ正直なとこなんですけども
今後俺は一体どうしたらいいんだろうといったことを色々考えながら動いてたんで
また今後ね、ちょっといろんな動きがあるかもしれないので
たくみとまさきと周りの人たちで
頑張っていければいいなと思っております
そんな感じ
周りに助けられながら皆で協力して
まあ無理せず
結構もう徹夜とか正直したくないから
なるべくこう無理しないかんじで
ちゃんと体調に気を使って
もう死んだら元も子もないからね
無理せず楽しくyoutubeやっていければいいなと思って
こういう決断に至りました
またちょっといろんな変化があると思うので是非皆さんお楽しみに
じゃあな
ＥＮＤＩＮＧ♪